i've been toying around with the idea of
like a
dreamed symphony as a very interesting
analogy for the nature of reality and so
whatever that source or that implicat or
that infinite consciousness
that that dimensionless singularity
that's
indescribable and indivisible that
that is in manifest
whatever the function may be of
self-determining its infinity whatever
the function
may be um it in a sense we can analogize
what exists right now as a symphony
in the sense that all of us
are artists in the symphony and that
again the idea of the illusory um uh
individual the the artist just not what
it appears to be
but that we we have this like unique
contribution like
you're going to play the clarinet i'm
going to play the piano someone else is
going to play the sax
and we're even if you play the same
instrument you're still going to play a
different
melody or a different harmony than other
people will
some people are maybe playing a little
bit more out of
tune because they're in like the service
to self
mentality they're still thinking
themselves as
the ego and separate and i mean other
people are in the service to other
they're playing in tune
um so in our like slowly our like
symphonic evolution has like the the
conductor is like the attractor we can
say in a mathematical system towards
like an
oroboros or whatever the telos is so
how do you like that like dreamed
symphony analogy i think not only is it
an excellent analogy it may be the only
viable analogy um let me try to tell you
why oh by the way i
i would prefer to say that i am the
violin being played and you
are the cello being played and i i like
that better
um expand on that too more for us
because advice you have a very dual
thing right i am playing the violin as
if the violin were outside of you
uh and then you have to account for that
duality
uh while if i am the violin being played
i am the result of the play
and that's why i'm different of you from
you and you are different from somebody
else we are all unique notes
being produced uh by this underlying
uh instrument um and and that
look the idea of notes appeals to
vibration what is a note it's a
vibration in
air which is produced by the vibration
of a
a string or a hammer or a column of air
in a
in an organ
and it is crucial to have this as the
metaphor it's the only metaphor i've
found so far because it allows us to
make sense of diversity
if all there is is oneness it's the only
way for you to explain diversity
if you postulate that only oneness is
truly real
um because diversity is then the variety
of vibrations or the variety of
excitations of that oneness yes um
if look a guitar string can you can
produce
different notes with it by plucking it
with in different ways
or by holding the the chord at different
different points different
holding the string at different points
but there is nothing
to any one of those very different nodes
other than that one string
right the only thing that's going on is
string
any movement but there is nothing to the
note
but the string if you remove the string
there is a note
it's like a ripple in water there is
nothing to the ripple but the water
in movement you can't take the ripple
out of the water
you can't do that if you take the water
away there is no ripple
the ripple is the water there is nothing
to the ripple but the water
yet you can have ripples of different
frequencies
patterns of movement heights momentum
direction
i mean that's how you get diversity from
oneness yes
it's the metaphor of vibration so i
think you're right on
wow i love that and i know that uh
sri aurobindo said that the um
the the diversity of the oneness is the
mathematics of the infinite
and yes look even science
is coming well a philosophical part of
science that arguably is not
real science but but it's very
interesting nonetheless m theory the
idea of m theory is that
everything uh all reality
is constituted of patterns of excitation
of a hyperdimensional membrane
or brain as they call it and you can
write all the mathematics for that
so yeah even even physics seems to be
heading in that direction i think it's
an
unavoidable insight patterns of
excitation
and i know this is getting so
interesting
i'm so pumped for for further um
explorations here who else have you
heard
talk about the um the dream symphony
because i want to research
them as well
i have a good friend um called uh fred
matzer
um he is publishing a book next year
he has a film out called beyond me and
he talks about it but
and i sort of plagiarized him a little
bit because he is the one who said
i am the violin being played yeah yeah
i'm not playing i am being played yeah
yeah
and his idea is that individuals don't
really exist they are illusions
so if they don't really exist they can't
be playing anything because they're not
there to play to begin with
but they may be being played they may be
yeah they may be being played yeah yeah
good and or orobindo also talked about
the body as the
receiving station for universal music
and yeah that's that's another metaphor
right here
same same metaphor yeah so this is so
interestingly triangulating on
the nature of reality and i'm so pumped
to embed
these beautiful wisdoms that you've been
able to share with
us plus also that you've been
teaching and that are also from all the
leaders because both of us
we stand on the shoulders of such
massive giants
and this this big synthesis
that i'm super pumped and passionate
about is
really the it's
it's the culmination of like the apex of
critical thinking around the nature of
reality and
and it's really really important to use
metaphor it's so important it enables
conversation at the highest levels of
abstraction
exactly and the way you you started the
interview you made
you said something in the beginning that
i didn't react to but i didn't forget
you were saying uh you know idealism
versus materialism mind versus matter
these are all dualities
yes they are and they ultimately hold
no water because there's ultimately only
one thing going on
the problem is and that's what you
alluded to right now to get
into the discourse we have to make a
concession
to the current rules of the game
so i make a dualist concession when i
label my view
idealism as opposed to materialism and
all the rest
because if you don't do that you don't
get into the conversation
now once you are in the conversation you
can make the conversation implode from
within which is my evil plan
but i have to get into it first
this is such such an interesting way of
viewing it is that there is this
there's this like bell curve that we
could call
like you know somewhere around maybe 95
or so people fit within two standard
deviations and we could call this like
the
evolutionary pacer um where
many people are focused on survival and
reproduction and many of the symbols
that are being exchanged
like memes are of uh kind of that
that that um they're they're not at the
uh the edges of the the bell curve at
these tails
because what's going on at the the
regressive tale
are still some people violence and
slavery
and it's all these bad things but at
this very progressive tale
there are people beyond two standard
deviations that are the ones that are at
the highest levels of abstraction
that have to then create some sort of
stories and metaphors like we gotta do
some
harry potter um pixar walt disney style
communication of the stories to get
um the center the evolutionary pacer for
people to kind of like
level up like we're shooting portals in
a sense for people to jump through
and like you said there has to be uh
sometimes this
like concession just because you can't
bypass the gatekeeper
unless you do these concessions or maybe
if you embed
the stories in animations or music or
other things but even then like i i
really like
your point we need myths we absolutely
need
the myths otherwise we don't have a
democratic process
so we need modern myths and we need to
take myths seriously
not literally seriously
bernardo wow such a powerful
conversation
thank you for joining us on the show i
had a lot of fun it was a
it was a pleasure i just looked at the
clock now it's been almost two hours i
had no idea
yeah yeah